- I'm waiting for death.
- A baby.
- Love.
(calm instrumental music)
- We're nurses, first of all,
so we're surrounded by it.
But death not necessarily in a bad way,
just knowing that it happens to all of us,
and I like to remind myself every day
that I am going to die
and it makes me feel like
this is what I wanna do today,
hang out with my friends in a
park and I feel good about it.
- A baby.
I want to be pregnant with a baby.
We had miscarriage a while ago,
so that's what I'm waiting for.
I had a strange miscarriage.
It was a partial mole,
so the fetus was alive
but it wasn't viable 'cause
it had 69 chromosomes,
and it was a silent miscarriage.
And after that kind of pregnancy,
there is a chance for a
specific kind of cancer.
So I'm like waiting for my blood tests
like over a course of months.
And I have two more months
and I'm in the clear.
So I'm waiting. (chuckles)
- What am I waiting for?
That's a good question.
Love, but I already have it. (laughs)
But I'm looking for more love
because that's the most important
thing in life, isn't it?
That's right.
- That is such an open-ended question.
Oh my god, it's so...
I could feel the gravity. (chuckles)
I guess I'm waiting for the
next big thing to happen,
whether it be love,
whether it be the next
big adventure that I take.
It's hard to answer that.
I guess it's like I'm
not waiting for anything.
I'm just waiting.
- [Thoraya] You listed a few things.
You said, "Whether it's love
when my next big adventure."
If it loves you, what
does it look like to you?
- It should feel comfortable.
It doesn't feel nervous,
it doesn't feel anxious.
It just feels like you found a friend
that wants to stay with
you for like forever.
And yeah, it just feels
like you found a friend
that you wanna do life with.
It's a loving partner, someone you just,
like anything you do in
your day you're just like,
"Wow, I wish that person
could have it too."
Or I wish we could bottle
it up and save it for them
so they could have if they're not there.
I guess that's what love
is, like in its purest form.
- I'm waiting for healing from people
who never healed themselves.
- A better circumstance.
- I'm waiting for the world to slow down.
- Right now, I'm waiting to
go to college and start fresh,
and I'm really excited for it.
- I don't know.
I guess I'm waiting for
like the right moment.
- I hope I'm not. (laughs)
Say I'd rather not wait
and do it now, I guess,
take the steps.
- I'm waiting to stop
being afraid of things.
I'm afraid of new things
and change and myself.
As much as I talk about
wanting to be more of myself,
it scares me to do that.
So I guess I'm waiting for the day
that I actually feel I can do that.
And I don't know if it'll
be like some big event
or like if there'll
even be a big catalyst,
but I guess that's what I'm
waiting for, to be myself.
- I am waiting for my super powers.
Like when you read all those kid books,
like "Harry Potter," and
you're like, oh what,
they're 11, 12 when they were like,
"Here's your letter to
Hogwarts," or something.
But I feel like it's all those milestones,
like 13, 15, 16, like the 18.
I'm like, well, I'm past all those stages
and I've not come in to any
power so I'm a little let down.
But there's still time maybe.
So I'll just keep holding out for it.
- That's a good one. (laughs)
You might wanna get his answer first.
That was perfect.
What are you waiting for?
- Cheese pizza.
(people laughing)
- Andrew lives in the moment,
and the next moment planned is dinner.
- [Thoraya] That's a
great answer, honestly.
- Right?
Like, of course, I have to think like,
"Oh, what am I waiting for?"
- I'm waiting to buy him
and her the cheese pizza.
(people laughing)
(calm instrumental music)
- I think that it's really important
to have a really positive outlook on life.
And I think that I'm waiting for myself
to get into my own
positive mindset and stop,
how do I say this,
and stop like blocking myself
from like, you know, achieving nirvana.
- I feel like I'm always waiting
thinking that, like, I
have a better opportunity
to do things like...
In my head, I know exactly how I wanna be.
I know things that I
don't wanna do anymore
and aspects of myself and
my being that I don't like
and that I really wanna change,
and subconsciously I
just continue to do it.
And then after the fact, I
realize I could have taken that
as an opportunity to change
in the way that I want to
and grow as a person.
And then I'm like,
"Dammit, I have to take
the next opportunity."
And I just need to realize
it before I even do it.
Yeah.
- I think I'm just waiting to
like find peace within myself.
It's been a really hard year.
I don't know whether it means, you know,
like be feeling confident in myself
or just kind of where I'm going in life.
I'm going to college soon
and I kind of don't know what I'm doing.
It feels really lonely sometimes,
and just, you know, it's really hard
to find peace within yourself
and like feeling okay and confident
when, you know, you feel really alone,
and like finding outlets,
it's really tough sometimes,
especially when you don't have
parents' guidance, you know?
Yeah.
- I am waiting to...
Yeah, I'm waiting to start my
life and I'm waiting for love.
I'm not a very accepting person of love,
but I found it in someone
and I found it somewhere.
Love isn't very easy in my family,
it's very reciprocated differently,
and I'm just trying to make sure
that I don't follow those footsteps.
Watching my parents marriage,
that's not the way that
I want my love to be.
I want it to be different and beautiful
and not full of disrespect
and unhealed trauma.
I wanna make sure that
I found my own self love
in a love with another person.
- These are more wishes, I
guess you could say, but,
yeah, I think for financial stability,
which would then being able to
maybe eventually buy a house,
maybe be able to take vacations.
But more importantly I feel
like it's more important
for everybody to be equal.
I feel like there's so many
people who don't have stuff
who work super hard for it,
and other people who work hard for it
but just get an exorbitant
amount of stuff.
- [Child] And pick me up.
- And pick you up.
And for this one to be healthy
for his entire life, right?
Yes.
(child laughing)
Oh, and since I'm a diabetic, I would love
to find cures instead of treatments.
- I don't feel like I
wait a lot, to be honest.
Like, I've accomplished so many things
and every time I put my mind
on like towards something
I kind of do it.
So I don't really wait
on anything or anyone.
I'm a professional skateboarder.
- [Thoraya] Oh no way!
- I just got back from the Olympics,
and, you know, I'm in San
Diego with my girlfriend
living life. (chuckles)
- I am waiting to find time
'cause, right, I have two jobs
and, of course, my family
just moved in with me
and so we're getting resettled
to go see my 100-year-old
mother because I love her
and she lives in Sacramento
so she's not real close.
And I never know when the last
time I'm gonna see her is,
and she taught me everything
that's important in life.
And I love her so much.
And I was thinking about it today,
tomorrow she could be
gone, but she's so awesome.
I'm a band and music teacher,
and I grew up learning music from her.
And my dad who had divorced, her said,
"Oh, I want you to do something else."
But you know what?
I am a band and music teacher.
And I make my living. I have two jobs.
I have a music studio
because my mom taught me
everything she knows.
And I love, have a passion for
music, and I just miss her.
So I'm waiting, I was
looking at the calendar,
I'm waiting to find a weekend
that I can just fly up
and just spend time with my dear mother
'cause I love her so much
and she's 100 years old.
- That's right really,
really good question.
Zoe, what am I waiting for?
I should just do it.
You know what? Don't wait for it.
Just do it.
That's my answer.
Now here for the first
time on your own channel,
you get it flipped around.
So Thoraya, tell us and
tell your dear viewers,
what are you waiting for?
- Well, I was just reminded
a bit by your answer.
You said you're a band teacher,
and my followers actually know this
'cause I've said it before,
but I've been wanting to
start a band with my cousins.
And I guess that's what
I've been waiting for.
I don't know what I'm waiting for, though.
Like, I don't even know where to start.
So I guess-
- [Band Teacher] Get those
cousins and get in a one room
and start jamming.
- (laughs) Is it really that simple?
- It is. My kids all play instruments.
We all sing and we just get together
and sometimes somebody
will pick up a guitar
and I run and get my flute and
she starts playing the piano.
He grabs a mandolin and we just have fun
creating with music.
- Now, we will tell you in the beginning
there might be a lot of, as Mom puts it,
creative dissonance.
You know, a lot of sounds that
just don't sound quite right,
but that's part of the creative process.
You gotta say, "I'm
willing to make mistakes
"in order to be willing to learn
"and take that willing to
learn and have fun with it."
Because it's all about having fun,
and if you're not having fun with it,
why do you wanna do it.
- Like, it's genuinely just
'cause I just imagine myself
playing the drums and it
brings me so much joy.
- [Band Teacher] There
you go. Get some sticks.
You don't even have to have a real drum,
you can bang on anything.
I teach band all the time.
- Do you teach drums?
- [Band Teacher] I do.
I teach percussion as part of the band.
- Do you do private lessons?
(people laughing)
- Oh-oh.
- I do everything.
- Okay, wow.
- [Band Teacher] Believe me, I
have taught hundreds of kids.
- [Interviewer] So the question is,
what are you waiting for?
- I don't know. I feel like...
Going back to what you
said, I just gotta do it.
- You do.
- You just gotta do it.
- Just do it.
Viewers, just do it.
Thoraya, just do it.
- Thank you so much. Wow.
- Yeah, have a great day.
(calm instrumental music)